luck plays such a big part in
songwriting you know I have this theory
that behind every successful songwriter
there's an astonished mother-in-law we
play diamonds are forever - Harry
Saltzman the producer and he didn't like
it at all he said the lyrics are filthy
touch it stroke it and undress it and he
thought John's music was very cliche
John said what the hell do you know
about Psalms and Harry went out slammed
the door but thankfully he's partner
cubby broccoli loved diamonds are
forever and soda Shirley Bassey and so
it went on and of course another
anecdote about that was I remember that
session was Shirley Bassey and sure he
said how do I sing this job how do I and
John Barry said because he had a way
with words John he said just think of
the diamond as a penis
and then she did it in one take now I
want to say one thing that may have done
a lot for surely he did nothing for me
where do you go from there you also
wrote the man with the Golden Gun for
Loulou
I did though I worked with Lulu earlier
on to Sir with love it's a film and it
was that was very happy experience and
Lulu was an obvious choice I don't think
John was very as happy as he was with
man with the Golden Gun as with the
others because it had to be written very
very quickly but we always when John and
I worked and I have to tell you we never
worked in the same room John was not one
of those composers that you see in
Mickey Rooney movies you know two
nervous guys smoking cigarettes with a
outta tune upright piano no John was
very much a loner he would want he
presented the tune to me always on every
song I ever wrote with him and when he
did present it it was more like an
unveiling because I knew he'd worked on
it honed it and and he and he didn't
think you could write great songs in the
same room that's why he didn't like
writing with contemporary composers he
thought the best songs were written
quietly with that mind-wandering lunacy
that you need and he once called me up
and said darlin I've been asked he said
buy this write a very hot writer she
only wants to come to my house and sit
at the piano with me and write a song so
he was very you know from the old school
is there a key to writing a great bond
song well I've always thought that the
best bond songs I think every Bond song
should have
well it should be seductive it should be
provocative it should have the width of
the boudoir about it they should have
the lure of the forbidden about it and
the music should be threatening and
mystifying and John Barry I think we're
here today to talk
bond and everything else but bond
without burying I'm sorry it would be
like Laurel without Hardy